[Musique]
les réserves pétrolières s'amenuisent
lentement mais sûrement ingénieurs et
scientifiques cherchent de nouveaux
moyens d'alimenter nos villes en énergie
le soleil la géothermie la fusion
nucléaire
le vent est un mélange des solutions
durables destinées aux gratte-ciel de
demain
dans l'une des régions les plus polluées
du monde un gratte-ciel de l'espoir
une tour qui respecte la planète qui
récolte les fruits généraux du soleil et
du vent qui puisse produire autant
d'énergie qu'il en consomme
ses concepteurs lui en donner un nom la
tour de la rivière des perles
si la réussite est au bout du projet une
nouvelle génération d'immeubles aura vu
le jour
le défi est colossal penser ou repenser
l'urbanisme du 21e siècle
sachant que plus de la moitié de la
population mondiale vit déjà dans des
villes
les immeubles consomme 40% de l'énergie
mondiale pour l'éclairage le chauffage
la climatisation
non seulement ces besoins engloutissent
de l'énergie mais il libère des gaz à
effet de serre
[Musique]
les architectes espère que la tour de la
rivière des perles sera une solution
d'avenir
cet immeuble devrait devenir le deuxième
gratte ciel de la ville de canton ou
guangzhou dans le sud de la chine
une nouvelle mue et d'architectes
soudaine pour mission d'améliorer nos
villes afin que les immeubles et laisse
une empreinte écologique minimale
[Musique]
parmi ces novateur rogers fréchette
l'ingénieur américain en charge du
projet de la tour perles
[Musique]
rogers est un spécialiste des énergies
propres appliquées au bâtiment
nous vivons un moment crucial dans
l'histoire industrielle du bâtiment les
grands problèmes mondiaux comme le
réchauffement climatique et la
raréfaction des énergies nous oblige à
repenser la façon dont nous traçons nos
plans et dont nous construisons nos
immeubles panechou et chongqing
travaille pour la société de
construction de shanghai il s'occupe de
chaque étape du travail sur le chantier
et supervise des centaines d'ouvriers
chinois
je fais ce travail depuis 20 ans et je
dois dire que c'est le plus grand
chantier de ma carrière
[Musique]
tayrac mondiale c'est la première fois
que je participe à la construction d'un
gratte ciel écologique
bien sûr on rencontre énormément de
problèmes techniques
tout au long de la construction c'est un
grand défi pour moi de gérer un tel
chantier
[Musique]
en finlande loin du chantier
risto jeu de scène et me soutient près
il est le concepteur des gigantesques
éoliennes qui vont permettre
d'approvisionner la perle des tours en
énergie je rêve que notre planète puisse
continuer à tourner sans qu'on a plus
que l'on fasse tout pour préserver
l'environnement
[Musique]
ensemble cette équipe internationale dès
qu un ingénieur se prépare à un défi de
taille
il espère que dans deux ans et demi en
lieu et place de ce trou se dressera la
tour la plus écologique du monde
[Musique]
rogers travail dans le développement
durable depuis plus de 20 ans mais aucun
de ces projets n'est comparable à celui
si jamais il n'aura concentrer autant
d'énergie renouvelable dans un même
bâtiment
mais pourquoi at on besoin de bâtiments
écologiques
[Musique]
nos habitations à nos bureaux nous
semble bien inoffensifs mais rogers
fréchette 7 à quel point ils sont
générateurs de gaz à effet de serre
lorsqu'on évoque le réchauffement
climatique et les émissions de gaz
carbonique
le public pense d'abord aux transports
aux voitures aux usines
en réalité les bureaux et les lieux
d'habitation et met encore bien plus de
co2
la chine est en train de devenir le plus
gros consommateurs de combustibles
fossiles de la planète prend aussi la
mesure de la raréfaction des ressources
en charbon et en hydrocarbures
il lui faut trouver d'urgence des idées
pour arrêter le gaspillage la façon dont
les citadins utiliseront ces bâtiments
et la façon dont ils y vivront ça c'est
une question cruciale pour l'avenir
grâce à l'essor économique de la chine
quand on est passé en une décennie de 8
à 11 millions d'habitants
c'est l'une des agglomérations les plus
pollués d'un pays qui ne compte pas
moins de 100 une ville de plus d'un
million d'habitants
[Musique]
m
la tour de la rivière des perles n'est
que l'un des nombreux gratte ciel en
chantier à l'instar de toutes les villes
de chine
quand on semble obsédé par la vitesse et
le toujours plus
la perle des tours fera partie du futur
quartier central des affaires dont elle
deviendra le joyau pour le moment ce
n'est qu'un énorme chantier d'apparence
désordonnée
[Musique]
mais tous les travaux devront être
achevés dans deux ans et demi lorsque
canton accueillera les jeux asiatiques
avec la paire le détour
la chine veut montrer qu'elle entend
balayer devant sa porte et perdre son
étiquette de nation la plus pollueuses
du monde
[Musique]
pour la première fois rogers fréchette
visitent le site de construction
il lui tardait de quitter son bureau de
chicago pour contempler le chantier des
fondations
mais ils découvrent et observe pour de
vrai son rêve en train de prendre forme
mais ce qu'il a imaginé ne deviendra
réalité qu'au prix de deux ans et demi
d'un labeur acharné mené par une armada
d'ouvriers d'ingénieurs
c'est ici que la grande idée sortira de
terre après être sorti du cerveau de
l'architecte un gratte-ciel
révolutionnaire intégré à son
environnement
pour tout dire écologiquement correct
édifier une tour qui aura le meilleur
rendement énergétique au monde
le pari est séduisant mais complexe la
recette miser sur plusieurs formes
d'énergie et non sur une seule réduire
les gaspillages les traquer un parent
assuré la production d'énergie propre
grâce à des éléments de technologie
inséré dans le corps même de l'immeuble
lequel devient une merveille
d'architecturé intelligente
dès le départ il faut jouer sur
l'emplacement et sur l'orientation de la
tour de façon à capter au mieux les deux
grandes énergies renouvelables que nous
offre la nature le soleil et le vent on
installe des cellules photovoltaïques
sur les façades bien exposé on donne une
forme aérodynamique haut gratte ciel
afin non seulement d'utiliser mes
d'accélérer le vent est de faire tourner
au maximum de leur puissance les
éoliennes inséré dans la tour
à la différence de la plupart des
immeubles et tours perles baigne
littéralement dans la lumière
c'est ce qui lui permet de produire une
bonne partie de son électricité
une couche protectrice en façade absorbe
l'excès de chaleur de façon à garder
l'intérieur frais sans avoir besoin de
recourir à l'air conditionné très
gourmands en énergie cette combinaison
de méthodes verte permet à la tour de la
rivière des perles de gagner tous et
paris
le site de la tour de la rivière des
perles
ici se dressera le gratte ciel le plus
écologique du monde là juste à droite
voici le trou pour le moment les
fondations ont été creusées à 28 m une
fois achevé le gratte-ciel pointera à
309 m pour mieux imaginer
il faut savoir que le bâtiment qui se
trouve à sa droite mesure 100 m le nôtre
grimpera à trois fois plus avant d'en
arriver là où hadjer devra surmonter
bien des obstacles non seulement les
imprévus propre à tout chantier
mais les problèmes inhérents aux
nouvelles techniques aux nouveaux
matériaux et aux différences culturelles
entre occidentaux et chinois
notre société a été invité par la
guandong tobacco company à participer à
un appel d'offres et nous avons eu la
chance de remporter le contrat
la tour de la rivière des perles a été
conçu à chicago pour faire aboutir ce
projet il était essentiel de rassembler
une équipe capable de le livrer avec
succès nous avançons jusqu'à un certain
stade dans la conception puis nous nous
associons un institut de design est un
cabinet d'architectes et d'ingénieurs
locaux nous collaborons étroitement pour
réaliser les plans qui serviront pour la
construction et voilà le bâtiment
commence déjà à sortir de terre
c'est beau à voir
le projet n'était encore qu'une ébauche
[Musique]
premier objectif les fondations
renforcée contre des risques naturels
la chine est l'un des pays du monde les
plus exposées aux tremblements de terre
l'agglomération de canton s'étend à
proximité d'une faille sismique active
le bâtiment doit résister à des
tremblements de terre d'une magnitude de
6 sur l'échelle de richter
[Musique]
panju et le chef du chantier
il dirige une armée de maçon de faire
ailleurs et de grutier il fait le lien
entre les bureaux des ingénieurs et les
équipes sur le terrain
ouais ouais
voilà la fonction consiste à établir des
plans de travail les transmettre ensuite
aux ouvriers à midi je me rends sur le
site pour juger de l'avancement des
opérations et contrôler que tout a bien
été exécutées selon les ordres
chacun d'entre eux a une tâche bien
définie on a une équipe chargée
d'installer les grues et une autre qui
pendant ce temps l'un s'occupe du
ferraillage
panju s'assure que les instructions des
ingénieurs sont suivis à la lettre
l'immeuble sera l'un des plus high tech
au monde
mais comme n'importe quel autre tour sa
base n'est qu'une forêt d'acier
[Musique]
rogers fréchette lui aussi se rend
régulièrement sur le site pour constater
l'avancée des travaux
à limoges
il est observé les différentes étapes de
la construction et voir son rêve devenir
réalité
ses collègues chinois le guide à travers
les échafaudages et les tiges de fer
dans sa vie professionnelle rogers passe
le plus clair de son temps dans des
bureaux
il saisit donc toutes les occasions
d'aller sur le site du chantier pour
voir ses projets prendre forme
tout semble se dérouler comme prévu
depuis sa dernière visite
les chefs d'état y compte et rien ne
doit être laissé au hasard
pendant que le travail sur le chantier
continue
rogers doit rejoindre les ingénieurs
chinois dans leur bureau ce rendez-vous
de coordination risque d'être
mouvementée certains ingénieurs locaux
se pose en effet des questions sur le
système de ventilation révolutionnaire
que vous installez le cabinet
d'architecte il semble sceptique
soit on passe par le premier système
pour décharger l'air soit on passe par
le second mais de toute façon la
quantité d'air décharger sera la même
je ne suis pas d'accord
permettez moi de vous montrer la
différence une situation classique pour
rogers l'innovation est inquiétant de
par nature une partie du travail d
esprit novateur consiste à combattre les
habitudes pour lever les doutes et les
inquiétudes
nul autre moyen que le dialogue je crois
que c'est très important c'est un point
sur lequel nous devons nous focaliser et
il nous reste peu de temps il serait
plus facile d'utiliser des méthodes déjà
éprouvé les architectes de la tour
aspire à révolutionner nos modes de
consommation d'énergie
je tiens à vous rappeler qu'un de nos
soucis
une de nos contraintes et justement
d'extraire ces terres chaud pour
convaincre rogers de se montrer dit le
mat mais ferme
il retourne à son bureau de chicago avec
l'assurance que le design sera bien
conforme à ses rêves
il ne reste plus que 18 mois avant la
date butoir le coeur de la tour a
dépassé le niveau du sol
mais les étages inférieurs sur loin
d'être achevé
ferrailleurs soudeur grutier les taux ne
rassemblent leurs compétences et leurs
forces
[Musique]
un étage prend forme et le processus
sera répétée 71 soit d'ici à la fin du
chantier
construire un gratte-ciel en deux ans et
demi est presque une gageure et afin d'y
arriver
les ouvriers continuent à travailler la
nuit
[Musique]
chongqing est le nouveau patron du
chantier il remplace pas le choix nous
ou que sa compagnie a rappelé d'urgence
pour un autre projet à shanghai
le destin du gratte-ciel reposent
désormais sur les épaules de cet homme
notre cage d'aujourd'hui sera de
bétonner la zone est
c'est un gros boulot qui va mobiliser
une trentaine d'ouvriers avant ce soir
nous aurons coup les mille mètres cubes
dans les autres zones où nous sommes en
train de mettre en place le ferraillage
pour demain sous une grosse journée
devant lui finie la ferraille pour cet
étage c'est le moment de couler le béton
coulé du béton est une opération
délicate
un coffrage mal étayée et le mortier
s'engouffre il ne faut pas on doit tout
arrêter nettoyez recommencer
d'habitude quand on gagne
[Musique]
le beau travail des ferrailleurs
disparaîtra pour toujours sous une
épaisse couche de béton
plus de mille mètres cubes de béton vont
être déversées ici en quelques heures
soit le contenu d'une cinquantaine de
camions toupies
[Musique]
toi loin d'être un peu sur les nerfs
l'arrivée des bétonneuses c'est réglé
comme un balai
le béton doit se déverser de façon
régulière
si l'on veut optimiser sa solidité et
ses capacités d'isolation
[Musique]
jusqu'à la nuit tombée le béton assez
cette coulée s'est enfin terminée de
l'autre côté du chantier les équipes de
faire ailleurs travaillent sans relâche
il faudra être prêt en moins d'une
semaine pour que le béton soit coulé pas
moins de 3000 chargements de camion
toupie seront nécessaires pour
construire les fondations de la tour
[Musique]
ronnie wood il ajouté
les directeurs du site vérifie le
travail des équipes et revoit les plans
en détail avant de donner les consignes
du jour des tonnes de fer à béton sont
livrés et positionner selon les plans à
chaque étape des géomètres veille à ce
qu'il n'y ait aucune déviation
transcendant
[Musique]
la tour s'élève lentement mais le
travail continue pour achever les
fondations dans le sous sol de
l'immeuble
[Musique]
le chantier emploie 500 personnes qui
viennent de toute la chine depuis un
demi siècle la chine fait face à un
exode rural massif
ces hommes et ces femmes quittent leur
foyer durant de longs mois et se font
embaucher sur les chantiers pour nourrir
leur famille beaucoup ne retournent à la
maison que pour le nouvel an chinois la
grande scène du pays
[Musique]
mais
ici c'est aussi la tour de babel si la
majorité des ouvriers sont de la région
de shanghai beaucoup d'autres viennent
de différentes provinces
chacun parle sa langue il y en a plus
d'une centaine différentes dans toute la
chine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le mandarin la plus répandue 17 langues
principales permet de se comprendre au
moins d'échanger les informations les
plus importantes
les sous sols sont finies et la tour
commence à s'élever il va falloir mettre
en place un nouvel appareil de levage
qui soit à la hauteur
nous avons fini d'installer cette grande
grue bleus de 54 m nous l'utilisons
poursuivre et de grosses poutres sa
charge utile atteint 64 tonnes ce qui
suffit largement à nos besoins
cet engin a la particularité de grandir
au fur et à mesure de la construction de
la tour
en réalité sa hauteur propres ne change
pas mais la grogne monte avec le sommet
du bâtiment
nous effectuons un test avec une poutre
de 20 tonnes nous sommes contrôlés par
une équipe du gouvernement effectivement
en chine le gouvernement ne laisse rien
au hasard
une fois qu'on a réussi à soulever
l'apôtre on effectue un test de
changement de direction
voilà
si ça fonctionne on saura qu'on peut
vraiment faire confiance à cet engin il
accomplira le travail pour lequel il est
conçu
[Musique]
mieux dans la guerre dans les métiers du
bâtiment l'intelligence et la force de
sa lle
la grue passent l'épreuve avec les
honneurs elle peut maintenant il sait
toutes ses charges et du même coup faire
re décoller le chantier en quelques
semaines la tour gagne 40 m
travailler à cette hauteur requiert de
la part des ouvriers des qualités
d'acrobates
on les surnomme les trapézistes ou les
voltigeurs ils ont désormais poser le
cadre dassier qui enveloppe le coeur de
la tour et supporte les étages
supérieurs
la corde de sécurité reste l'instrument
de travail indispensable
les trapézistes chant d'excellents
grimpeurs mais leur mission reste
dangereuse
ces sommes doivent ajouter la précaution
à la prudence
un outil lâché peut tuer quelqu'un qui
passe en dessous afin d'assurer le
parfait équilibre de la tour les poutres
d'acier de plus de 10 tonnes doivent
être positionnés avec une précision
millimétrique
le conducteur de la grue travail avec
les trapézistes pour guider les lourdes
pièces les voltigeurs a juste boulogne
soude
ici on ne connaît pas le vertige
trapéziste ferrailleurs couleurs de
béton grâce à u depuis un an le travail
a bien avancé
un nouveau pas de géant doit être
franchie nous sommes arrivés à un moment
crucial de nos travaux au coeur de la
tour l'installation de notre système
auto élévateurs à vérin hydraulique
grâce à cela nous pourrons démonter nos
échafaudages et samo porteurs sont déjà
installés le système auto élévateur est
quasiment en place cet appareil est
unique en chine
tous espèrent qu'avec lèvres bleues il
permettra de boucler le chantier dans
les temps
on va pouvoir exécuter tous les travaux
sur le noyau le coeur de la tour à
l'aide de ce système commandé par
ordinateur ce qui va grandement
améliorer notre efficacité
on passera de 12 jours par étage à
seulement 4 ou 5
un rythme qui nous permettra si tout va
bien de hisser le noyau à 300 mètres en
8 mois
chen chen yuan est le seul spécialiste
en chine de ce genre de système voilà
les cadres de support nous allons les
fixer avec des boulons ainsi on aura
aménager une plateforme suspendue à
l'intérieur même du noyau sur laquelle
les ouvriers seront à l'aise pour
travailler aujourd'hui chaîne doit
coordonner l'installation de toutes les
plateformes du coeur de la tour et les
structures bleus de l'extérieur afin que
les ouvriers puissent oeuvrer en toute
sécurité sans aucun échafaudages c'est
tout se passe bien la colonne vertébrale
de la tour de la rivière des perles
s'élèvera d'un mètre par jour
[Musique]
ce colosse est capable de manipuler ces
éléments gigantesque avec une extrême
minutie
[Musique]
en contact permanent avec le conducteur
de la grue chaîne pilote chaque pièce
vers son emplacement
[Musique]
toutes les équipes oeuvrent de concert
pour que les éléments du gratte-ciel
s'ajuste au millimètre et à la minute
près le puzzle en trois dimensions
devient réalité
[Musique]
c'est que nous sommes en train
d'assembler remplace l'échafaudage
intérieur et on peut le modifier en
fonction de la structure du bâtiment
lorsque nous coulons le béton de ce mur
le coffre s'élève automatiquement en
saber temps à l'anatomie de la tour
grâce au fameux vérins hydrauliques
par exemple si les tâches mesure trois
mètres cinquante de hauteur
le plateau est réglé pour s'élever à 3
mètres 50 juste et permettre d'attaquer
aussitôt les étages supérieurs
les ouvriers peuvent sans retard
commencer le ferraillage puis posé le
coffrage dans lequel un autre béton sera
coulé et ainsi de suite jusqu'à 300 m
c'est ça le processus
[Musique]
le chantier avant si bien que la tour
est maintenant visible de loin et
commence à s'intégrer au quartier elle
atteint 100 m presque le tiers de sa
hauteur finale
outre après qu'outre le travail des
voltigeurs se poursuit
le corps de la tour n'est plus le seul à
grimper les étages suivent tient un
journal
non messieurs rien à carrer clients les
étages dans utilisant une technique de
pointe pour construire le plancher c'est
une technique déjà utilisée en europe
que nous avons adapté à nos besoins
le plus grand avantage de ce plancher en
acier galvanisé c'est qu'il offre un
système sans sucre à ce qui veut dire
que l'on n'a plus besoin d'échafaudages
pour le soutien par en dessous quand on
trouve du béton ont construit
directement après la mise en place du
plancher sert donc de coffrage porter et
dispense d'utiliser un étayage permet
d'associer étroitement acier et béton et
le cadre peut supporter le poids du
béton et des personnes qui travaillent
toute l'opération devient efficace
rapide et sûre
installer un plancher de ce type il faut
une dizaine d'ouvriers qui travailleront
pendant trois jours après il faut
compter un jour pour le ferraillage un
jour pour le bétonnage et si on ajoute
les travaux d'assemblage
en tout on a quasiment besoin de quatre
jours supplémentaires
après l'état j'ai terminé les progrès de
la construction rassure un visiteur
privilégiées l'ingénieur rogers
fréchette
voilà ce que sera bientôt un étages de
bureaux dans notre gratte ciel imaginons
nous transporter dans un ordre voici ce
que nous verrons d'abord un système
d'aération par le sol l'air arrive par
en bas sous nos pieds
il s'élève naturellement à travers toute
la structure
c'est ainsi que la perle des tours
renouvelle son oxygène au plafond des
panneaux métalliques de forme concave
ils sont refroidies alors température la
plus basse
ils induisent des échanges thermiques
par rayonnement avec les personnes
présentes dans la pièce
pour cette dernière ce sera une
étonnante sensation de confort à
l'extérieur du bâtiment
on verra ce qu'on appelle une double
façade ventilation interne quand le
soleil entre en contact avec la surface
de la tour
il réchauffe l'air qui se trouve entre
les épaisseurs vitré ses terres remonte
le long de l'immeuble et peut être
utilisé à d'autres fins
[Musique]
leur voyage le long du mur externe
il s'élève entre les épaisseurs vitré et
l'intérieur ce mouvement même refroidi
le vert et maintient une température
agréable dans les étages l'excès d'air
chaud et ramener vers un étage technique
nous réutilisons son énergie à
différents endroits de l'immeuble
depuis ce promontoire rogers explique
comment par son implantation même la
tour peut produire de l'énergie dans la
conception de la tour de la rivière des
perles
il faut impérativement prendre en compte
le contexte la situation de la tour et
son environnement
le gratte-ciel s'élève près de l'axé
central du nouveau quartier d'affaires
de la ville de canton
il se dresse au nord-est de la zone à
cet emplacement
il a pour ainsi dire un accès direct et
illimité à la lumière du soleil presque
toute la journée le soleil tourne dans
le ciel mais grâce au grand parc qui se
trouve devant la tour il n'y a
pratiquement jamais d'obstacles entre
lui et la tour en orientant de façon
optimale de gratte-ciel par rapport au
soleil l'architecte a misé sur sa
puissance de rayonnement
cette énergie propre sera captée sur les
façades est et sud par des cellules
photovoltaïques de dernière génération
qui non seulement produiront de
l'électricité les contribueront à la
climatisation
ce qui se passe aussi à guam jour c'est
que les vents dominants souffle du sud
presque toute l'année
lorsqu ils traverseront le nouveau
quartier d'affaires
il ne se heurteront à aucun autre
immeuble avant d'actionner les éoliennes
de la tour de la rivière des perles les
vents viendront directement entraîné les
turbines sans rencontrer aucun obstacle
au bout du compte les énergies de l'air
et du soleil alimenteront l'immeuble
avec un rendement optimal xiaosheng
rejoint rogers pour une inspection
générale des travaux aujourd'hui nous en
sommes au 22e étage le niveau où se
trouve la turbine de l'éolienne il ya
quelques jours nous en étions encore là
le temps de construction de chaque étage
était d'environ 12 jours nous avons sont
de plus en plus vite
après dix étages nous en sommes arrivés
à un rythme de construction d'un étage
tous les trois jours
nous avons repris confiance
nous aurons fini à la fin de l'année
cet immeuble sera l'un des quatre
bâtiments les plus hauts de la zone la
tour de télévision se trouve là bas et
on distingue la place jeanne chine plus
loin le premier étage technique se
trouvera un étage au-dessus de l'endroit
où nous sommes en ce moment c'est là que
nous installerons les éoliennes au
niveau du sol
on ne sent pas beaucoup le vent mais à
cette hauteur il souffle une petite
brise agréable c'est parfait je suis sûr
qu'une fois en place nos éoliennes
feront merveille
elles produiront énormément d'énergie
mais comment installer au milieu d'un
immeuble des zéros lienne sources de
bruits et de vibrations c'est bien connu
la réponse rogers et son équipe la
trouve en finlande
l'homme qui a inventé et perfectionner
ces éoliennes verticales s'appelle reste
au jeu de scène est mis il ya une
trentaine d'années j'ai une véritable
révélation concernant les éoliennes
depuis 30 ans que je travaille j'ai
découvert leur avantage caché ce modèle
là on a infiniment plus que les autres
l'université de vaas à est reconnu pour
son travail de recherche dans le domaine
de l'électronique
risto qui a établi son laboratoire avec
ses collègues il met au point un système
pour surveiller ces turbines à distance
il peut vérifier la vitesse et la
direction du vent la puissance générée
est utilisé en plus une webcam pour
dépister d'éventuels problèmes
restos a besoin d'enregistrer toutes ces
informations pour améliorer cette
technique et la reproduire dans la tour
de la rivière des perles parlant plus
c'est ce que nous allons essayer de
faire un chine nous aurons quatre
turbines et quatre moniteurs et dc nous
pourrons voir ce qui se passe en chine
et savoir quelle est la production à
l'avenir
ce pourrait être l'occasion d'une
magnifique collaboration avec
l'université
les concepteurs de la perle des tours
ont choisi la société de hristo pour
offrir à leurs immeubles and atouts
écologiques hors pair c'est la première
construction de ce genre dans le monde
cette tour à la forme d'une voile de
bateau
ce qui veut dire que le vent exerce
dessus une très forte pression
la plupart des autres immeubles gère le
van houtte roulement en essayant de
l'écarter nous nous le récupérons lect
ça le sud et par là le nord par les
vents dominants souffle du sud avec ses
étages et au lien ou l'air s'engouffre
dans des tunnels avant d'actionner des
turbines la tour de la rivière des
perles utilise un phénomène physique
bien connu en dynamique des fluides
l'effet venturi les molécules d'air sont
accélérées par le rétrécissement plus le
vent forcit plus grande et l'énergie
qu'ils communiquent aux éoliennes
on a déjà expérimenté ce type de
turbines et on connaît sa capacité de
production d'énergie un méga watts par
mètre carré en moyenne pour cette région
de la rivière des perles devant des
chiffres aussi impressionnants
on a évidemment envie d'essayer c'est un
projet vraiment passionnant ce que je
vous montre est un modèle spécial de
turbines mètres de diamètre et 4 de
hauteur
c'est la seule éolienne adaptées à
l'environnement urbain
elle est totalement silencieuse c'est un
modèle spécial qui peut tout à fait être
installé au coeur d'une ville comme vous
voyez une éolienne classique et ellis
n'a pas sa place sur un immeuble trop
bruyante mais regardez la nôtre sur le
toit d'en face on n'entend rien c'est ça
notre spécialité
il faut parler aussi de certains aspects
écologiques ont peu touché c'était aux
liens à mains nues sans aucun risque
c'est la seule qu'on puisse approcher
tandis qu'elle tourne à plein régime
regardez le vent est d'environ trois
mètres par seconde
mais la rotation reste relativement
lente et c'est pourquoi cet engin est
sans danger
sa vitesse axial dépend d'un système de
pignons à taille variable
c'était owlient sera parfaite pour la
tour de la rivière des perles
grâce au système novateur de hristo des
éoliennes feront pour la première fois
partie intégrante d'un bâtiment
sur le site de l'immeuble les ouvriers
s'apprête à construire laitages où
seront installées les éoliennes
[Musique]
ici la façade serait précis pour
accélérer le vent qui s'engouffre rats
dans les turbines à cette altitude
les architectes ont calculé que le flux
aériens subirait une accélération de
250% un énorme bonus son énergie
[Musique]
jean revenir au haut karabagh
des poutres aux formes bizarres
permettront d'amorcer la courbure une
parfaite structure pour les éoliennes
un cauchemar pour les équipes de
construction
[Musique]
voici la dernière grosse poutre a posé
avant l'installation de la turbine
comme pour les précédentes sont ajustage
est un casse tête
cette poutre métallique pèse à peu près
21 une tonne le fait qu'elle ne soit pas
rectiligne en nous causent bien des
problèmes
il faut redoubler d'attention on a
beaucoup de mal à déterminer son point
d'équilibré et a trouvé son centre de
gravité pour pouvoir la soulever
correctement
une manoeuvre de haute précision
[Musique]
après plusieurs tentatives la dernière
poutre d'acier s'inscrit enfin dans le
ciel la quasi-totalité du 18e étage est
désormais construites toutes les poutres
ont été boulonné et soudée total pour ce
seul niveau 400 tonnes
tout doit être contrôlé et recontrôler
s'il subsiste un problème il est urgent
de le déceler la sécurité des niveaux
supérieurs en dépend
nous sommes en train de hisser les
poutres d'acier nécessaires à la
construction de laitages des éoliennes
pour tout le monde
en arriver à l'état joue doivent être
installés les fameuses turbine à quelque
chose de symbolique et de fort
ingénieur chef d'equipe ouvriers ils ont
tous tellement donné de même que la tour
de la rivière des perles sera bel et
bien prête lors de l'ouverture des jeux
asiatiques de canton
ce sera pour la chine un succès un
symbole du futur lundi ce qu'une
importante étape est franchie
la preuve qu'on peut édifier des
bâtiments à la fois moderne et
écologique
[Musique]
c'est un véritable défi pour nous mais
c'est ce qui met du piment dans
l'existence nous avons les connaissances
et l'expérience pour mener à bien un
chantier comme la perle des tours
toutefois je suis certain que nous
appelons devront encore des choses
passionnantes
pendant la réalisation de ce projet
[Musique]
regardez cette tour est le premier
gratte-ciel vraiment écologique de chine
on n'a jamais construit un immeuble de
cette taille rassemblant 11 techniques
différentes pour réduire la consommation
d'énergie se gratte ciel vert est
conforme aux récentes directives du
gouvernement chinois qui misent
ouvertement sur les nouvelles
technologies et les énergies propres
et je suis particulièrement fier de ce
bâtiment écologique
à l'heure actuelle le monde entier ce
souci de la protection de
l'environnement et je suis certain que
les idées mises en application dans ce
projet sont excellentes
je crois que notre gratte ciel vert
deviendra un exemple à suivre pour de
nombreux architectes dans le monde
entier je suis convaincu que la tour de
la rivière des perles constitue un pas
en avant décisif dans la conception des
bâtiments écologiques
j'espère qu'elle sera une source
d'inspiration qui donnera d'autres
envies d'aller plus loin encore
si le rythme de travail se maintient la
construction de la tour devrait
s'achever dans les temps ce gratte-ciel
écologiques conçus pour être
autosuffisant en énergie pourrait faire
école devenir un modèle pour nos futurs
immeubles
[Musique]